hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to last case the
disappearance of Amanda Kane now the
reason I picked this game to plays
because of this it looks ok it was a
little monotonous I wasn't sure if
anyone was talking there but because of
this and how I'm parently playing a
moose character and I need to go answer
the phone
chop down the rest of history and went
over to the desk yes I did exactly all
those things the money was good
Injection as hell didn't have the luxury
of being picky these days okay Connor
didn't leave him a lot of information to
go on okay write quickly wrote down two
names two became the daughter and the
pink flamingo some shady bar somewhere a
heart I thought there was someone else
who was Jack's best bet but he had to
find out that it's hard to dress well is
this before the age of the Internet what
can I now find this out all right then
fine I'll look at my books younger
especially a young rich girl okay then
I'm gonna do exactly that
Seth I'm a girl cuz I'm a private eye
mousse loaded with heavy bullets hey I
can see how it's rendered in amazing
detail actually this is really cool I
like this yep is he dead it was his
morbid little ritual before age
yeah he's dead great this is this is a
typical film noir like detective story
and it's actually really cool like it's
almost like it was a cliche and now it
hasn't been used in a while
cool but now it's kind of not a cliche
anymore so hopefully this will be quiet
yes it were was it another cliche how
dare you oh well this doesn't seem very
storm-like at all where am I are they
dere am i moose what am I not a place
for pink flamingos maybe the owner was a
bird lover Jack thought you guys were
sitting in a corner having a heated
discussion about last night's game yeah
another was passed out on one of the
tables oh I didn't even see that he's
very flat okay indeed he was I just
noticed her drowning his guilt in booze
after his partners did we mentioned that
the partner is dead he couldn't cheat
death he couldn't do it
total you two can sit at the bar in
order to bourbon yes please bourbon I
think the last one was lonely where
enough haha
a drunk Private Eye hmm so he still
asked him about Amanda he just looked at
the human kept on wiping the bar great
customer service I'm gonna write this on
yep as bad or maybe there anything else
I can well at least you're keeping the
place clean
okay all right can I get oh dick jar
there's no such thing as free
information the bartender just pointed
at the back door and told Jack to talk
to a guy named Sam Erie Jack go to the
back door and the barman busted or open
Hey looks very good saying having to
leave a bar through the back door no not
at all I've never done it before in my
life
hello are you samiri is that Sandford
semi we will speak singing old fans I
was talking and that'd be kinda painful
right the big flamingo my brain went
somewhere else
my breath Oh does that stand for taint
punch fellows does that stand for the
plowing [ __ ] does that stand for the
penis [ __ ] does that stand for these
prongs are fresh does that stand for
that prick Frank does it stand for does
that stand for - because it's not funny
it's not funny at all ok all right
hmm hi Samaria
oh I thought that was this ambience
music ok so do I need to do something
about that how about I blow it all up
with that help jack once over and turn
the music off no I won't piss off you're
on the ground you wouldn't want me to do
that another attempt to start a
conversation good language sir
I'm gonna really good you yeah so now
I'm gonna drop the ban on you
I got a pipe of some other sort except
it's a gun
okay I don't know who her friends this
is back when she's gone
yeah
cool no life lessons for everybody here
if you have a good they had cleared out
one of his accounts and had taken off
yeah okay okay and was slowly making his
way to the cabin he thought very loudly
to himself as he exposition his way to
the cabin oh okay nobody was banging
apparently because nobody's home but
nobody appears to be home yes good signs
all of them means a raging kegger
happened fuse box yes please
the fuse box was completely fried why
was there a flashlight under the fuse
box okay whatever damn right jack did
Jack also jumped over candlestick
chuckles joking around the cabin got wet
it became clear to him that they must
have left him home maybe samira had
tipped him off a strange green light was
coming through the windows yes most of
the furniture started to 3000 my exit
vehicle and ran outside Jack didn't kill
Sam
I think it sounds oh okay it's aliens Oh
stinky mop until you okay there's gonna
be little film noir I did it rapture
happen come on purgatory
we're done we're done we're done
can't be done nothing happened why did I
get abducted by aliens
why was aliens part of that at all those
aliens right it couldn't have been
anything buddy aliens it was it was a
film noir with a cliche drunk divorced
dead partnered investigators looking for
a donor who ran away with a boyfriend
for a rich dad all right okay that makes
sense to me if it doesn't make sense you
I mean what's wrong with you that made
perfect sense we're so thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
for participating in this experiment in
madness
so life lessons college ever zoo lory if
you're an alien you'll understand what
that meant so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you
in the next video